not everyone uses sequel but if you do
wouldn't it be nice to be able to use
machine learning within your sequel
environment bigquery ml does just that
stay tuned to find out how welcome to AI
adventures where we explore the art
science and tools of machine learning my
name is Yu fango and on this episode
we're going to try out
bigquery ml which enables you to create
and execute machine learning models in
bigquery using standard sequel queries
currently bigquery ml or BQ ml for short
supports linear regression binary
logistic regression and multi-class
logistic regression linear regressions
are models which predict a numerical
value like an insurance premium or a
home value binary logistic regressions
are models which predict one of two
classes like identifying whether a
machine needs to be checked for
maintenance work yes or no or perhaps
more famously whether an image is a cat
or a dog multi-class logistic
regressions are models which predict
more than two classes for example
whether or not you should buy hold or
sell a stock or if say traffic on the
highway is light medium heavy or a
parking lot let's see what BQ lamelle
looks like in practice you can access it
via the bigquery UI or through the
command line and API today we'll look at
it on the bigquery UI but the queries
we'll use are identical to if you use
the command line or the API I've got
some sample data here from Google
Analytics taken from a bigquery public
data set we did an episode on the
bigquery public data sets program a
while back so be sure to check that out
to learn more about all the public data
sets that are free for you to use now
let's take a look at our data set today
notice that we're looking specifically
at whether or not a transaction took
place that's what we'll be trying to
predict later on now what will we base
these predictions on we have the
operating system of the user's device
whether
was a mobile device or not the country
of origin and the number of page views
that the user performed I have a feeling
in that last column that it's probably
going to be pretty useful notice also
that we're pulling data from this sample
data set from between August 2016
through June of 2017 okay let's try
building a model to see if we can make
some predictions based on these criteria
on these columns we'll add a create
model statement at the top with the
table name and give our sample the name
say just sample model and we'll pass in
some options including the fact that
we're doing a logistic regression so
we're just going to say yes or no one of
two options whether or not transaction
took place well we just put that at the
top of our select statement and that's
really the only edit you'll need to turn
your query into a model now while that's
running I want to point out that the
aliasing on that first column of
transactions to call it a label that
wasn't a coincidence BQ ml looks
specifically for a column named label so
that it can figure out which column you
want to predict on and which are the
columns you want as inputs so if you
don't want to create a column called
label for some reason or if you have a
column actually called label that you
don't want to use this label you can set
the input label calls option in the
create model statement say we call that
column transactions instead right and
there was no column called labels then
we could do something like this where we
pass in the name transactions as the
column to look for as our label what's
really handy about BQ ml is that you
don't need to move your data anywhere to
take advantage of its features since
it's built right into bigquery this
means that it can serve as a really easy
way to get a first look at any notable
patterns in your data once your model
has started training you can check out
the training statistics if you want
click on the model on the left hand
panel and go over to the model stats tab
down below there you can see the
training progress as it works through
the data set and improves the model
performance with each pass
now when the create model statement
finishes running it's time to run
evaluation using ml dot evaluate will
take the original sequel query that we
had for the data set and wrap it in ml
evaluate passing in the newly created
model and then selecting from that
result you will get an output that
includes a number of different metrics
of your model notice that we've actually
queried dates that are outside of the
range of the training data and
specifically it's the month immediately
following the dates that we used to
train on we don't want to pass in a
training data for evaluation because
that would be like cheating on the test
finally it's time to run predict here
we'll wrap that same query we use during
evaluation with the ml dot predict
function and pass the model in as well
this particular prediction groups up the
countries so we can see what their
predictions are for each country ranked
we can also see that for this particular
data set most of the transactions came
from the United States though it might
be worth diving in deeper to see how
these match up across mobile devices and
different operating systems so that's
big query ml in a nutshell a simple way
to do some easy machine learning right
within your sequel environment I'm
looking forward to seeing what models
you build thanks for watching this
episode of cloud AI adventures and if
you enjoyed it be sure to hit that like
button and subscribe to get all the
latest updates right when they come in
for now check out bigquery ml and start
building your first model today
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]